[MUSIC PLAYING]
GABRIELE GARZOGLIO: My
name is Gabriele Garzoglio.
I am a cloud consultant with
the Professional Services
Organization at Google.
I'm here with my collaborators
from Cardinal Health,
Ed Hammond, Louis Verzi,
and Walker Miller.
The way we have structured our
talk today is in four sections.
We'll start talking about the
challenges and best practices
about application migrations.
I'll tell you how PSO,
the Professional Services
Organization, can help you with
application migration using
a methodology called
Cloud Sprints.
I'll let you hear
directly from Cardinal
Health about their experience
with Cloud Sprint or the use
case.
And then I'll come back and
talk a bit more technically
about what we do with you
when we do a Cloud Sprint.
When we start working
with a customer
to talk about
application migrations,
the first thing we do
is assess the maturity
of their infrastructure.
And there are many
ways to do this,
but one way is
really understanding
how much cloud ready they are.
And so, if you
look on the y-axis,
there is the on-prem
amount of computation
that the customer does
versus how ready they
are for public cloud.
On the x-axis, you can actually
see whether their operations
are more classical,
sys-admin-oriented type
of operations versus more
cloud native CI/CD-based DevOps
operations.
And of course,
most customers want
to be on the top right
corner, where, of course,
you have the productivity.
You have the
portability of the code.
You know, you pay
for what you do.
But what we often observe is
that customers are actually
on the lower right--
actually, lower left,
where everything
is more rigid and expensive.
And so, how can we help--
we, PSO-- help you move towards
the top right corner here.
And of course, we work with you
to understand how to integrate
your CI/CD processes with GCP.
And the other thing we do is
also to help you with lifting,
shifting your virtual
machines or your servers
from your on-prem
environment into GCP.
So as we do this, we
observe that there
are challenges that everybody
faces during these migrations.
And there are both business
challenges as well as
technical challenges.
I mean, some of these
things-- without going
through the full list, right?
But often, we put
together teams,
and then we see
that there aren't
enough experts in a
given area to actually do
things hands-on on the cloud.
Often there are
decisions that needs
to be taken about the
direction of the architecture.
And you know, there are
maybe no decision makers
available at that
time to talk to.
Some concerns about the
flexibility of the design.
Sometimes, you know,
there are other concerns.
The way we like to
organize these activities
is really as a
agile methodologies,
where we do iterations of the
designs and implementations
until we get to a point
where you want to be.
Some of the technical
challenges is really
about the lack of
automation culture.
I talked about helping you
integrate CI/CD processes
with our cloud.
The closer you are to the
right-hand of the graph,
the better it is.
Sometimes, there is
the idea that we want
to do everything all at once.
And, you know, the
boil the ocean type
of activity, which goes
together with the expectations
mismatch on the left.
And so, as a cloud consultant,
my job is often say,
let's go over this carefully.
Make sure that we identify some
good first mover so that we
can create an
infrastructure for you
and then migrate into
this infrastructure
a good application, where
you can start testing things
and really popularize the work
that you are doing with us.
We structure the
journey of a customer
through our service offerings
in these four different type
of activities.
We do assessment.
We plan with you.
We talk about how
you can deploy and do
the migration of your
applications on the cloud.
And once you are
there, we can consults
on how you can
take best advantage
of the cloud with
some optimizations.
So after you have
done a lift and shift,
you can start using your
environment already.
And then you can start
using native cloud services.
And, you know, this is a whole
journey that, if you want,
PSO can help you with.
And for this talk today,
I'm going to talk more
about the foundation.
So how we design foundations
for your environment in UCP
to receive your
applications, and then
talk a bit about how to
do the implementation.
And throughout this
journey, we keep in mind
a few best practices that
I can tell you about.
The sooner you have a
production-quality foundational
environment, the sooner
you can start actually
using your cloud for real.
There is a lot of focus on
our side to really automate
the deployment of
foundational elements
and really designing them
for your actual needs.
In everything that we do, we
always consider security first
From The first
discussion we have
until we get to the
optimization phase,
and really try to
understand not only
how to deploy the foundation
in an automated fashion,
but also how you can
automate the deployment
of your applications.
As I mentioned before, we
organize these activities
in Springs, where we can
actually do iterative design
and implementation,
so that every time you
can get a feeling for
how the infrastructure is
going to work.
And then I talked about,
again, making sure
that a first mover application,
the one that you start
moving into your application
to popularize the work you're
doing, is a good one.
And so, I'll focus
a bit in this talk
about the foundational
aspect of things.
And when I talk about
foundational aspects,
these are the things
that I'm talking about.
Again, selection of
first mover, which
is the important piece here.
And then, we want
to do user identity,
either through G Suite
or cloud identity.
Resource organization and access
management go hand-in-hand.
I'll talk more about this.
How you decide to
structure your organization
has strong implication on how
you want to implement policies
on this hierarchy of resources.
We always recommend using groups
and roles to access resources.
I'll talk more about
that at the end.
And then, of course,
we spend a lot of time
doing network design.
So talking about the
connectivity to on-prem
or to another cloud, the
topology of the network,
and all the network
services, DNS,
and so on, so forth,
BGP, et cetera.
Security.
Again, we can work with you
to understand your security
objectives, and
then understand how
to implement that proactive
security controls,
and then what we call reactive
security controls in the sense
that we can have
scanners that check
your environment
periodically and can fire up
alarms when the configuration
is not what you expected.
Talking about the type
of computing environment
that are important for
you, and then, of course,
start talking about operations,
because at the end of the day,
you do your migration,
but guess what?
You're going to have to change
somewhat your operations
to make sure that you take
best advantage of the cloud.
Now, how do we do it in PSO?
How can we help you with this?
For application migration, the
typical approach that we take
is offering you a
consulting service
called the Cloud Sprint.
And the Cloud Sprint
is really one week
of intense work preceded
by some preparation, where
we work together.
We do together a
workshop for a full week.
And we work
elbow-to-elbow to design
a foundational
infrastructure and start
working towards implementing
this infrastructure with you,
and then migrate maybe a
couple of applications, one
or two applications.
We do this, essentially, with
identifying their workloads,
the good first mover, building
the foundational elements,
migrating the workload,
and then understanding
at the end of this
week, once we are off,
how can we keep helping
you, or how can you
take this and move it
forward by yourself.
We talk about GCP.
And it's a chance
for us to educate you
and for us to learn
from you on what you
are doing your infrastructure.
Security, as I
said, is always very
important in everything we do.
Select the first
mover, and then the
really instantiate the
production-ready cloud
foundation, and migrate
the production workload.
When I say
production-ready, I'm saying
that all the elements of a
production infrastructure
is going to be available to you.
It may require still
some work to tailor it
to your specific needs.
So, for example,
when you do auditing,
we can integrate the GCP
logs with your same solution,
whether you use Splunk
or some other solution.
But of course, the alarms
that you want to trigger on
are going to often be
application-specific.
So then, when you get to
the point of configuring
the new infrastructure
to respond to your needs,
then you can move it from
production-ready to actually
production.
This is a typical way
we organize the sprints.
They are meant to be
very parallel in nature.
And we start generally with
this technical infrastructure
kickoff, where we
talk about GCP,
and we learn from you
about your infrastructure.
We spend most of
the day doing design
on the first day, elbow-to-elbow
whiteboarding sessions.
And then already
the first day, we
sit together on your computers.
We look at what we have
decided to tackle first
of the foundational
elements, and then
implement it in GCP with you.
Always talk about
security and then
split into multiple
work streams, where
each work streams tackle one
of the foundational elements
plus the application
development, so
the application deployment,
so the actual migration
of the workload.
If you look at the
yellow lines, you
will recognize the
foundational elements
that I was discussing before.
One thing that is important
to work well on these
together is that there is a
need to have enough people that
are experts in these various
areas in your business
so that we can actually split.
We'll bring enough
people, enough engineer,
enough consultants, but we
need to be able to pair up.
The last day is
making an assessment
of how well we did during
the workshop, and, in fact,
how ready the infrastructure
is for production activities.
Every day, we take that ideal
situation and we reassess
it based on your needs.
This is a real-life example
of something that we did.
And we agree on how to split in
groups to actually accomplish
at the end of the
day what we want
to do for your specific needs.
And this is an example
of the assessment
that I was discussing before.
You see the two columns,
the workshop outcome,
and the production
readiness column,
how well we did
during the workshop,
and how ready the infrastructure
is by topic, which is typically
the foundational elements that
we have identified for your use
case.
One of the best
ways we can be sure
that we know where the
percentage of errors
in deploying the infrastructure
is by automation.
We have libraries of
infrastructure as code
that we share with you.
And we work with
you elbow-to-elbow
to configure so that
we can collaborate
on the infrastructure
and the code
of your foundational
infrastructure.
Of course, the
consistency is improved,
because you can check
the stuff into git,
and then avoid the manual
error by doing peer reviews,
typical debugging techniques
that you can do now on code.
And of course-- and force
policies proactively.
After this talk,
around 4 o'clock,
my colleague is going to
talk about more details
of this infrastructure
that we have,
the cloud foundation
and the automation.
I forget exactly where.
The hotel?
The national hotel?
It's not in this building.
It's one of the
building that's outside.
What I can show
you is an example
of what we do, for example,
for provisioning projects.
I mean, creating
a project is not
everything you need to start.
You need to then instantiate
the computing environment
that you want to use,
enable building, enable
the APIs that you care,
create the service accounts,
IAM policies, and
so on, so forth.
And you can script all of
this by using our templates.
Now, I want to give Ed a chance
to talk about their experience
with GCP.
ED HAMMOND: Is this on?
Yeah, OK.
My name's Ed Hammond, and
I'm with Cardinal Health.
Cardinal Health is based in
Columbus, Ohio, Dublin, Ohio,
suburb of Columbus.
And our mission is to
make health care more
efficient for providers
and, in the end,
trying to help our patients
have better health care.
So our cloud philosophy
has been very simple.
We want to enable agile
teams, development teams
to be very effective.
Speed, agility, cost
efficiency, those
are all the great buzzwords.
Traditionally, Cardinal Health
has been a shared services--
classic shared
services model, where
there are silos of specialists
doing specific tasks.
And we're trying to
break down those walls
and enable agile teams
to be self-sufficient,
so they're able to quickly
adapt and experiment
with new technologies.
The GCP project design, the
notion of a GCP project,
fits our model perfectly for
doing that because that helps
us set the security
policies and everything
for those agile teams.
The security by design.
We started with building in
the controls right up front.
What you'll notice right
in GCP is that the project
is a unit of authorization.
So you can set authorization
controls at the project,
so we have tight controls
about how we create projects.
But beyond that, we delegate the
controls to the app-dev teams.
And the self-service and
automation as Gabriele
mentioned.
You want to always provide
tools, documentation,
and consulting services.
Rather than having a large
shared services team,
we want to have a
small cloud expert
team that can go around and
help DevOps teams be sufficient,
self-sufficient in the cloud.
So we provide documentation.
We have a wiki that has
lots of documentation on it.
We consult and help
people build things.
We have a number of colleagues
in the audience that do that.
But at the end of the
day, we want our teams
to be working on their own,
so that they can really
experiment, test,
learn, and grow.
So how do we do this?
One of the key things
we learned early on
was that the network
is pretty key.
So our design is basically
to use two host projects--
if you're familiar with shared
VPCs and host projects--
to use two host projects,
one for production,
one for non-production, and
create shared VPCs under that.
Then the project teams
are using service projects
that consumes those PCs.
We have tight controls over
internet Ingress and Egress
patterns.
We're using various
different security appliances
and techniques for doing
those kinds of things.
But we worked very hard at
setting that up upfront.
So before the Cloud Sprint
engagement with PSO,
who did a great job, by the
way, we had all this set up.
It took us about three months
working with our account team
to learn how it all
worked, because we
went from zero knowledge
to three months,
we had it all built
and ready to go,
and we started going
into the sprint.
Our application teams
manage their own projects.
Again, typically, they'll
have one service project
for production, one service
project for non-production.
And then we set up the IAM
roles, customize IAM roles,
at the organizational level.
And we delegate that down and
use service accounts and AD
groups.
We map them over for owner
and editor privileges
within each one of the projects.
The service accounts
for VPC firewall rules,
that's really key to us.
So that when you
create an instance,
it's using a service
account, and that
gives the authorization
for that instance.
We're also doing it
for routing rules,
so it can do the
Ingress/Egress patterns,
as well as for the VPC
firewall rules for east, west,
and north, south traffic.
As Gabriele mentioned,
we always want
to have everything scripted.
So wherever something is
well-known, well understood,
and repeatable, we try
and do it in scripts.
So when we built the networks,
are project creation process
is all scripted.
Creating service accounts
and so forth, those
are all scripts that we use.
With that, I'm going
to turn it over
to my colleague, Louis Verzi,
who is a cloud evangelist.
LOUIS VERZI: So they let us
make up our titles when we
were doing this presentation.
So I thought about what
I do on a daily basis.
And my official title
is senior engineer,
but I feel like my
job at Cardinal Health
is really making sure
everyone understands
what the benefits
of the cloud are,
and what they can
achieve in the cloud.
So that's where I came up with
the cloud evangelist title.
I want to tell you a little
bit about our sprint engagement
and how that
experience was for us.
And there's really
two messages that I
want to share with you that
I want you to take from this.
The first is to be ready
or be prepared going
into your sprint engagement.
And the second is to
view the sprint, really,
as taking you the last mile
into your journey in the cloud.
So obviously, Google's
going to meet you wherever
you are in the process.
So if you're on the
first mile, don't feel
like it's not time to engage.
But for us, really, taking
us the last mile really
helped out a lot.
So plan ahead, understand
the technology,
play around with the services.
We had four to
five engineers that
were researching Google
technologies in the two
months leading up
to our sprint, kind
of talking about
our culture, how
we wanted to Google
technologies to fit in,
really, how we wanted
to design overall.
And so, by the time the
PSO engineers came on-site,
we had a lot of our
design complete.
That allowed us to vet
a lot of our designs
and make sure that
we were thinking
about all of the things that
we should have been thinking
about, that we weren't
leaving anything out,
that we weren't being
stupid about some stuff.
And so it was really
helpful for us.
So I'd encourage you,
if you're starting,
if you're early
on in the process,
to do some research on
VPC strategies, cloud
identity, resource
hierarchy, and custom roles.
Those were some key
areas that we understood
where we wanted to be when
the PSO folks showed up,
so that we could make the
most progress as possible.
So being prepared
allowed us to get
into details like how
to deploy and configure
for SETI, building a billion
showback model and data studio,
defining our
organizational policies.
So it was still in
alpha when we deployed,
but the organizational
policies really
allowed us to feel much more
comfortable about giving out
the keys to projects, because
we could still put some controls
in place, right?
We could put a policy on
saying no one can create
a resource with
public IP addresses,
because, I don't know
about at your company,
but our security
folks aren't very
keen on workloads that
should be internal
having public IP addresses.
We were also able to integrate
our organizational Stackdriver
logs into Splunk.
We also ran multiple
work streams in parallel.
So we had several
conference rooms
that were dedicated to
the sprint engagement.
And we had sub-teams
that were breaking off.
It was a lot of planned
chaos for the week
that they were on-site
with all the things
that we had going on,
but it was great to be
able to make a lot of progress
in a short period of time.
That kind of gets us into
one of the use cases.
So we had four
application teams that we
were able to bring up
on GCP during the week
of our engagement that had
never used a Google Cloud
Platform before.
And like Ed was saying,
we wanted self-service.
We want automation.
We want application teams to be
able to do things themselves.
So those application
teams, they had support.
We were in the room.
We had Google in the room.
But our attempt was--
which we were successful at--
was giving the application
teams the tools
they needed to deploy
their own resources,
not to have us to
deploy the resources,
to have them script out
their application installs
so that they'd
have repeatability.
So one of those teams was our
Splunk infrastructure team.
So Cardinal's been in the
cloud a few years now.
Our Splunk infrastructure is
on another cloud platform.
For many different
reasons, we wanted
to move that into Google.
So during the spring engagement,
we moved our dev environment
from another cloud provider
that likes the color orange
into GCP.
At the end of the sprint, they
had built deployment manager
scripts for their whole stack.
They had migrated subsets
of their data over into GCP
so that they knew
what they were doing
when they got to production.
They were moving
subsets of sample data.
And really prepared themselves
for a successful production
migration the following month.
So Splunk was the first
production application
we had running in GCP about
a month after our engagement.
It also laid the
foundation for them
to be able to explore
an elastic environment.
So in our prior
cloud provider, there
wasn't this concept of projects.
There's accounts,
but you can't easily
manage hundreds or
thousands of accounts.
So it was a multi-tenant
environment.
People didn't have the ability
to spin up their own resources,
because if you gave
them the ability
to spin up and delete
their resources,
they could spin up and delete
other people's resources, too.
Not a good thing.
So GCP allowed them to build
an elastic infrastructure.
So as they need
to add resources,
they can add resources.
They don't need to engage a
the cloud team to add resources
to their environment.
They modify a script
and execute it,
and they have more indexers
or more search heads.
Like I said, since we could
delegate more permissions,
they're able to explore and
improve upon their processes
rather than be dependent
on a centralized team
to do everything for them.
So that was our experience with
the Google Sprint Engagement.
And really, like I said before,
Google met us where we were at.
So if you feel like you're
not sure where to go,
they can get you to
where you need to go.
If you feel like
you've got a good plan,
but you want a
little bit of backup,
make sure that someone
that's done this before
is making sure that you're
not doing something stupid,
it was great for us.
It really was effective for
Google to be able to meet us
where we were at
in our lifecycle.
I've engaged many vendors
in my years in IT,
and I do have to say that the
Google Professional Services
folks are far and away
more experienced and more
knowledgeable than
any other vendor
that I've brought
professional services in for.
So it was definitely an
awesome experience for us.
And with that, I'm going
to turn some time over
to Walker Miller, who's going
to talk to you about our efforts
with containers
during the sprint.
WALKER MILLER: Thanks.
See if this worked.
All right.
So probably like a lot
of enterprises out there,
we got a go forward
strategy of utilizing kind
of for in-house development,
a combination of PaaS and FaaS
was kind of our first approach.
But when you look at
Cardinal's compute footprint,
we're really only about 15%.
Internally, the developed
applications, we have about 85%
common, off-the-shelf software.
And obviously, we can't
do a lot with that
as far as trying to
determine what we think
might be a best practice for it.
We have a limitation.
What we've kind of
identified is probably
the biggest possibility for
all that stuff is to move them
into containers in Kubernetes.
We see a lot of
cost optimization
and just a lot of
benefits that you
get from living in
kind of a container
world with consistency,
speed, et cetera, right?
So as part of that, we have
very limited experience
when it comes to
containers and Kubernetes.
We've had some success
in the PaaS world,
but that's largely because they
build the containers for you.
And we're going to have a
team to really support or do
any of that.
So we get to kind of
start from scratch.
And so it was pretty
easy for us to choose
to kind of partner
with Google very early
on to help us kind
of build that muscle.
And so, we brought them
in for that first sprint,
which was about a week long.
We had a track
that was two days.
And we just said, let's get
a container done, right?
And that's what we
started with was just one.
So we took kind of
what we identified
as some of our
container-friendly partners.
In our case, we focused in on
IBM and their WebSphere stack,
WebSPhere Application Server,
WebSphere Message Broker,
and WebSphere MQ
are all things that
work pretty well in
the container world
and IBM has a good
level of support for.
So we weren't just kind
of out on a limb on it.
Nobody's too excited about using
those technologies anymore,
but they still exist for us.
And they're not going to
go away, unfortunately,
anytime soon.
So we took the first
steps, and within two days,
we were able to get one of
each of those up and running.
And again, we had one person
from each of those teams
internally working with Google.
And neither of them had--
none of them had done anything
with containers before.
So that sprint ended up
being as much as we could
get done in two days, we did.
We had a good idea for what
the process would look like.
However, you're only going
to make so much progress
in two days.
So we brought Google back
for an additional month
to focus in on just the
WebSphere application server
stack.
And our goal with
that was to get five
to eight applications done.
And we did.
And really, what we
wanted to focus on
was building a factory.
So WebSphere applications
are pretty cut and paste
for the most part once
you get it up and running.
And we wanted that
full-blown kind of pipeline
that we could use to
build our containers.
And so, Google came
in, helped us out.
And we were able to-- by
the end of that month long,
we had a factory.
We had five applications up
and running, at least one
of them fully tested.
And we, more importantly,
had a pipeline.
So since they've
been there, we've
actually gotten an
additional six applications
that are up and
running, including
in our e-commerce
application, which
is our big bread
and butter, right?
And that's a full-blown
WebSphere stack.
I won't go into detail.
So it was very, very,
very successful for us.
Yeah.
That's it.
I'm good.
Back to you.
GABRIELE GARZOGLIO:
Thank you, Walker.
All right, very good.
So I wanted to
spend the remaining
time I have to talk a bit
about the type of decisions
you need to take when
you go on implementing
your automation for
the provisioning
of the foundational elements.
Ed has talked a bit about
the use cases on networking,
and Louis has mentioned
some of these elements.
I wanted to spend a bit
more time on these four
on the board, the bold ones.
So selection of the first mover.
I mentioned that it's important.
There are some business
characteristics
and some technical
of a good first mover.
If we talk about the
business characteristics,
you want something
that is not really
business critical for
your first example.
But on the other hand, it
shouldn't be an edge case.
You want to use this first
mover as the way you go back
to your executive, saying,
look, we have migrated X,
and this is important to us.
Let's make sure that now
that we have migrated X
that we can migrate
everything else,
and you get support because
of the importance of x.
You can actually then build
the knowledge base out
of this experience.
And then, of course, we can
afford the cutover window,
et cetera, et cetera.
It doesn't have compliance
challenges, ideally.
On the technical side,
you want something
that is really not very
dependent on other services.
As you start moving the
application to the cloud,
you don't want to have to
take everything else that
comes with it.
You know, maybe it has less
integration with GCP services,
and so on, and so forth.
I mean, pictorially, if you
look at a design diagram,
like maybe that box, the red
box, may be a good first mover.
Doesn't have a lot of
dependencies with other things.
So maybe it can be deployed
with CI/CD techniques.
And maybe this one is not
so good because of the way
it depends on everything else.
What we do, we go through
diagrams like this with you,
and we help you select
what a good first mover is.
Then resource organization
and access management.
Now, Louis was mentioning before
that they were implementing
security policies, for
example, to prevent
the provisioning of public IPs.
Now, this is what
you want to think
about when you want to then
implement security and access
policies.
The resource hierarchy
allows you to do
good separation of duties.
It allows you to implement
the access security policies.
Building isolation is
at the project levels.
And then you can
control quota and limits
through this hierarchy.
And generally, what
we recommend is, well,
let's start thinking about
the simplest infrastructure
we can design for you.
And this is actually
a very simple one,
where you have projects.
And then you put them
together into folders
that are environment-specific.
Now, each one of these
nodes in this hierarchy
is a place where you
can actually implement
access and security policies.
So you can say, well,
in the dev environment,
I'm not going to
have my developers
provision public IPs,
but maybe on production,
I do need public IPs.
And so, you can change
the policies that way.
Now, this is simple.
But in this example, for
example, where do you
place your shared services?
And so, then maybe you
can think about something
that is a bit more complex,
where you maybe still retain
the environment-oriented
approach.
But then you maybe
have something that
is shared-services oriented.
And, you know, this is good.
It's enable the separation
for shared services.
It preserves their
environment separation.
But the drawback is that
it's more complex than before
and maybe you need still
something more complex because,
for example, if you have
multiple business units,
where are you going to put them?
And so, we can go
on in the discussion
and maybe you can
add another layer.
You can have at the
top the business units.
And you end up
having something that
is pretty granular for
your access controls.
You know, it's
easily extensible.
You have a new business
unit that you want on board,
it's easy to do.
You know, it's a
complex structure,
so it comes with complexity.
The fact that you have to
manage your groups or your roles
very carefully.
And also, the network topology.
If you have, say, one project
that manages your network,
then you want to be careful
about how you give permissions
to other folders
in the structure
and the projects
inside those folders
to get access to the network.
So together, we generally
all go through something
like this, some
discussion like this,
and then decide which one is
the best hierarchy for you.
Together with the
hierarchies I mentioned
goes access management.
So how is the access management
implemented in Google?
If you look at
this diagram here,
you have that you have
identities at the top.
You have individual
identities, robo identities,
or service accounts, and
then you have groups.
Groups can be a
collection of those two.
These identities
are granted a role.
And the role is a set of
permissions over resources.
What we recommend
always is that you
give access to your
resources, role
to your resources from a
group, because, this way, it's
easier for you to
manage the membership.
If people come and go,
you have a structure
that is well thought out of.
And to the zeroth
level, what we recommend
is to start simply with maybe
for organizational level
groups.
We have the org admin, you
know, defines the IAM policies.
It can implement the structure
that we have discussed before,
can create projects.
Although, eventually, maybe
this responsibility can be
delegated.
You have a network
administrator group
that has the responsibility for
creating the network topology
that then the rest of your
environment is going to use.
The network administrators
in this picture
maintain the firewall
rules, and you
can decide whether this
function is something
that the network administrators
do or the security
administrators do.
That's part of the discussions
that we're going to have.
You have a security
admin that, at a minimum,
has visibility on the resources,
establishes the role--
so the custom roles that Louis
was talking about before--
and then establishes
the policies
at the organizational
nodes of the structure
that we were discussing before.
And then you have somebody that
is responsible for setting up
the building accounts,
monitoring the usage,
granting access to using
the billing accounts
to project owners, and so forth.
So, you know, these are what
we recommended as a minimum
for organizational level.
And then, of course,
there are folder-
and project-level groups.
And these actually change a
lot depending on your business.
You always have some kind of
reliability engineer or some
kind of DevOps operation ,
where the developers develop
in an environment and
then collaborate with
the reliability engineers to
actually do the deployment
through CI/CD.
And then you might have some
kind of data analyst figure
that you want to
create a group for.
Now, for every one
of these groups,
we recommend a set of roles.
And as I said, these rules
are sets of permissions
under the resources.
So in this example--
I have only one example--
you have the compute
network admin that creates,
modify, and delete
networking resources,
except for firewall rules
and SSL certificates.
As I said before, you can decide
whether to give that permission
to the network administrators
or your security administrators,
and so on, so forth.
Now, one thing that we also do,
start talking about operations.
Once you have the
foundational layout,
you have your application
in your environment,
you need to make sense of it.
And operations has
multiple Facets.
One thing that I thought
I'd talk about with you
is really that
billing and analytics.
One thing that we
always recommend
is make sure that when you
create your organization,
you go to your account,
billing account,
and you export the
logs to be queried.
This allows you to do
at least two things.
One thing is you can use SQL
syntax to query your billing
information.
And so you can
start having insight
in your billing information.
The other thing you can
deploy out of the box
is Data Studio dashboard
that can display information
about your billing so that, as
you configure these dashboards,
you can create
automatically reports
that maybe you can share with
your CFO or with your VPs.
Key to doing good
billing is really
defining the labels that
characterize your resources.
So labels can be, for example,
associated to cost centers,
maybe to business units.
When we, PSO, come
on-site with you,
we have that discussion
with you, right?
How should we organize the
labels to view your billing?
At a minimum, you
have the granularity
at the project level.
But automatically, things like
Data Studio, this dashboard,
can pick those label and
create reports for you.
And the way to do
it, you know, there
are instructions
on how to do it.
And we go together
over these instructions
and create a Data Studio
dashboard for you.
Now, these are the few things
that I wanted to pick out
of everything we do.
In short, what we
have discussed is
that lift and shift is a good
way, together with integrating
your CI/CD processes,
to modernize your IT
infrastructure.
PSO can help you
with a methodology
called Cloud Sprint.
It's one week of work.
You had heard from
Cardinal Health
their experience using
sprints and working with us.
And then you want to
automate everything
that you do for
creating your foundation
and deploying your applications.
And we discussed some
of the concept one
needs to go through to really
implement these concepts
in infrastructure as code.
[MUSIC PLAYING]